this is the first time i've ever joined
in but i've been watching your videos
and uh
um i get a lot out of it you know i'm a
divorced uh
51 year old i got divorced uh
back in 2013.
so i kind of been on this track that you
guys are going like you and uh
kevin samuels uh i just came across you
guys videos
and um i find it interesting that
there's a lot of other men out there
that think the way
that i was thinking so i appreciate
these videos that you guys uh
have been putting out trying to get
these uh men to be alphas
i personally felt i was a beta when i
was married
and once i got divorced i changed that
story um i learned a lot and
a lot of the things that i learned is
what you guys speak of right now
to the uh boundaries right i'm sorry
just about setting some health healthy
boundaries and holding yourself in a
higher
regard a lot of guys you know they just
[ __ ] despairs themselves so much
right i think what happens a lot when
guys tend to be betas they kind of
feel sorry for themselves and they
listen to the story that it was all
their fault as to why their wife went
out and cheated and did all this crazy
stuff
but what they need to know is that men
do have rules and we need to go ahead
and let people know that we have rules
it's not
all about what women want so um
did your wife go off and cheat on you
like what happened with your marriage
yeah it was a story well you know i was
one of those guys that took care of kids
and
uh went to work brought my money home um
i thought i was doing the right thing to
keep a woman my father never sat me down
and taught me how to
you know you know vanessa woman if you
want to call it that he never sat me
down and told me the things that i
actually tell
my 23 year old son now about how women
work
but yes she did go out i was home taking
care of the kids she used to go to new
york to say she was seeing her cousin i
was living in boston at the time
and uh you know it wasn't that she
wasn't going to really see your cousin
so um came home you know and you know
how we are as men with territory when it
comes to our women
and uh you know come to find out she's
sleeping with another guy and then
coming home sleeping with me
so that really bothered me and i i had
to go to anger management over it
so i didn't go to seek uh help
you know mental health because i was
going through a lot of other things at
the time
but uh i don't know there's a lot of
guys out here but what i would just say
is
you don't need to accept that and you
don't need to go through those emotions
that
uh you know uh it was somehow your fault
because
she said it was your fault you know the
whole thing about
uh you know you you ignored me
you you know that type of stuff just
because you were doing the things that
you like to do
never take never take ownership i mean
if you know you were doing
stuff like that uh ignoring your wife or
whatever then that's on you but
if you felt you were being a really good
person and taking care of business the
way
women say they want guys to do never
take ownership of
why a woman cheated on you she did what
she wanted to do
yeah and that's why you know i made the
point earlier
when it kept popping up there in the
comments about
loyalty you know guys wanting loyal
women and it's like
women are women you know they're going
to do what they're going to do
you know if they see you as their best
option and their hypergamy satisfied
you're in a pretty good place but that's
not guaranteed for life man you know
when you take these vows you know
they sell guys a [ __ ] you know build
a sale when you go to
go to church and you or the you know the
courthouse or wherever you do your
ceremony it's it's
you know in sickness and health and
richer and poorer
until death do his part and blah blah
blah it's like you know okay fine
you know i i took the vows i kissed her
i gave her the ring we had the ceremony
we cut the kate we kissed
you know ding ding ding on the crystal
glasses and all that sort of stuff
okay so you think that you've done your
duty and she's never going to do you
wrong but
hypergamy doesn't care right right so
that's the disney channel stuff you know
what i mean the harlequin novels they
try to teach us that
you know uh if love at first sight and
all this stuff about
knight and shining armor and women
believing in that
and uh yeah guys it's not true
i always say to my friends like it
doesn't matter what you have i know a
lot of people are talking about the you
know women wanting high quality
high value men and all and when it comes
down to it if a woman doesn't want you
it doesn't matter what you have
so what's your um what's your position
right now because now you're divorced
you got it sounds like you got some
grown kids you date you kind of do your
own thing like
uh how do you deal with them in today
now
i think i'm i i don't know some people
would say i'm a little brutal because i
just don't put up with a lot of
bs i don't want to curse on your channel
but i don't i don't uh
put up with a lot of bs i i find that if
i can't talk to a woman about
any topic like i had a woman
kind of back off of me because i brought
up a video
that kevin did and you know
kevin's speaking in my opinion he's
speaking a lot of truth about what guys
don't want to deal with
and that's you know you know the things
he talks about women with bad attitudes
you probably you say it too i've watched
a lot more of his videos than yours but
i've seen a lot of your good
snippets um so the way i deal
now is like if you
i'm kind of like listen i got the rule i
have rules too if you don't fall in line
with
a lot of my rules i mean i'm willing to
listen to you see what your rules are
like
but uh if you don't fall in love with my
rules i delete your phone number
i mean there's only certain things and
i'm not being ridiculous about it i just
have certain
boundaries that i don't allow women to
cross
you know if i find that women are you
know
i'm not a chaser so i'm like you know if
you really like me then you're going to
show me that
you're not going to you know sit back
and
i'm the one always reaching out to you
i'm the one always calling
you do you ever get lectured by women
you know because of that position
because you're setting bound boundaries
yeah we'll tell you off they don't tell
me off i'm not going through that stuff
but um
block delete yeah you know it's just
real simple i'm not going to argue with
anyone
once i got divorced i told myself
through those years where i was
rebuilding myself
that um there's no need to argue
you're going to believe what you believe
i'm going to believe what i believe
at the end of the day if it's you that
want to get married one day and you want
to
go towards that road then you're gonna
have to act a certain way to get there
and i'm a person that's i'm not really
looking to get married again if
if it happens if i meet that person and
that person makes me feel like i want to
be with her
for the rest of my life then i'll make
that decision but uh
right now you know i go out with ladies
i have fun i go to the gun range with
them and
you know go out to movies and go to eat
and do a lot of that stuff
but even recently i haven't been uh too
keen on getting sexual with a lot of
women because they try to use that
as uh some sort of crazy way to
get their emotions and craziness
involved so and what age range are you
dating in right now
like you're 51 you said right yeah um
so i've dated 26 i well i was i was 49
when i dated a 26 year old
and i go throughout the race i've dated
women older than me
um they just have to be active like i am
i ride bikes i go to the gun range i
go to the gym i do all these things to
kind of
keep myself alive and make myself look
better i can't ask for better if i don't
look better
so i like it hey listen there's a uh
super chat here from odin he says dana's
wearing
his rich cooper t-shirt what what what's
on your shirt there looks like oh this
is god of war this is kratos
yeah okay i've i've i've played a little
kratos i've played a little kratos you
know people
people started calling me kratos of the
manosphere and i didn't even know what
the hell that was so i decided to go
look it up on the playstation i just
downloaded it for shits and giggles to
see what it was all about okay yeah i'm
here listening to your games too i'm 51
years old i always tell people i come
from that era where we'll ne
i'm never going to stop doing the things
that i like so
i'm going to be one of those old guys
that still listens to hip hop and r
b and play games this is this is my
divorce life
you know what man this is this is what
mental point of origin looks like so
guys
listen up because this because this
man's 51 he's divorced he's been through
the grinder he saw what it all looked
like
you know he's in the sexual marketplace
today now where he puts himself first
tolerates no nonsense
and he's living life on on his terms
this
this man here is the real mgtow okay
i appreciate that take note all right
dana i'm gonna let you go because i got
a bunch of other guys sitting here
waiting
thanks for bringing me in yeah man
thanks for sharing see you all right
peace
you